two members of the Navy's SEAL Team six
are under investigation this morning in
the death of an army green beret 34 year
old Staff Sergeant Logan Melgar was
found dead on June 4th he was reportedly
strangled in embassy housing in the
capital of Mali Navy investigators have
taken over the case to see if the seals
had any connection to his death David
Martin is at the Pentagon David good
morning good morning after weeks of
revelations about US military operations
in the African country of New Year
another operation is coming to light in
the neighboring country of Mali another
American soldier is dead only this time
it's a homicide army green beret Staff
Sergeant Logan Melgar died last June in
a house he shared with the two Navy
SEALs in the capital of Mali an autopsy
ruled his death a homicide reportedly by
asphyxiation a law enforcement source
says the two Navy SEALs had been
involved in an argument with him and are
now under investigation by the Naval
Criminal Investigative Service
neither the Pentagon nor the u.s. Africa
Command announced Sergeant Mel gars
death apparently because it would reveal
the presence of special operations
forces in Mali Sargent Melgar was a
member of the same Special Forces group
as the four Americans who were killed
while on patrol in the neighboring
country of Nazaire earlier this month
the Islamic state fighters who ambushed
and killed the 4 soldiers were based in
Mali and escaped back across the border
a Texas native Melgar was honored at his
high school's homecoming football game
earlier this month the Pentagon is still
struggling to explain the sequence of
events which led to the deaths of those
four soldiers in Nazaire now it must
explain the death of Sergeant Melgar as
well as what American special operations
forces are doing in Mali Gail thank you
very much David